prot qui vont devoir qui ne finit
d'augmenter juste savoir quels risques
que le risque du décrochage d'une
mutuelle n'accentue pas voilà ceux qui
ne pourront éventuellement peut-être pas
se payer ce pays leur mutuelle le reste
à charge de zéro on en a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est aussi la qualité enfin mon
chien à l'ass et on a connu des systèmes
comme ça par le passé c'est pas un
système très innovant il ya eu il y
avait sur certains territoires fin voilà
d'aidé panier de soins on revient sur le
panier de soins ce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
avoir les moyens baron ce panier de
soins avec une parle de prothèses
adapter les autres iront vers des
solutions plus innovantes et voilà s'il
ya aussi ce risque de déséquilibrer
peut-être d'inégalités sous jacentes
mais ceci dit je tiens quand même à dire
que effectivement c'est quand même c'est
une conquête
je voudrais gression un peu je voudrais
ajouter sur sur cette conquête
importante justement que la meilleure
façon de faire qu'il n'y ait pas
d'augmentation des cotisations sociales
c'est pour ce panier de soins
spécifiques reste à charge roux qui
concerne la sécurité sociale et les
organismes complémentaires mutuelles ce
soit le parlement qui décide du panier
de soins et qui décide des tarifs